Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. If a person fatigued with long and hard labour, or with a violent agitation of the mind, takes a good dish of chocolat, he shall perceive almost instantly that his faintness shall cease and his strength shall be recovered.
感谢您收听《历史余韵》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。如果一个人因长期艰苦的劳动或剧烈的精神波动而感到疲惫，喝上一杯好巧克力，他几乎会立刻感觉到虚弱感消失，体力得到恢复。
So that, Dominic, was written by Monsieur de Queloux, who, as you're probably able to tell, was a Frenchman. Was he? He was writing in the early 18th century. Yeah. And that was translated into English in 1724. And it is from the Natural History of Chocolate. And you may be wondering what qualified Monsieur de Queloux to opine on the subject of chocolate. And you may be wondering what qualified Monsieur de Quelou
所以，多米尼克，这段话是由德·克卢先生（Monsieur de Queloux）所写，正如你可能看出来的那样，他是一位法国人。是吗？他是在18世纪初写的。是的。那段文字在1724年被翻译成英文。它出自《巧克力自然史》（Natural History of Chocolate）。你可能想知道，德·克卢先生有什么资格对巧克力这一主题发表高见。你可能想知道，德·克卢先生有什么资格
to opine on the subject of chocolate. And it was because he had actually, he'd spent time out in the Caribbean, in the French West Indies, where he had been utterly converted to the notion that chocolate was not only tasty, but good for you. I completely agree with him, Tom. But you will find a very shocking French opinion coming up. Right. Because in the opinion of Monsieur de Quelou, he said that one ounce of chocolate contains as much nourishment as a pound of beef. An ounce of chocolate? Yeah. I'd want more than an ounce. One ounce of chocolate. But I mean, as an Englishman, a proud Englishman. Yeah, absolutely. Would you agree with that, that chocolate outweighs beef?
对巧克力这一主题发表高见。这是因为他实际上在加勒比海的法属西印度群岛待过一段时间，在那里他彻底被一种观念所折服，即巧克力不仅美味，而且对你有益。汤姆，我完全同意他的观点。但你很快就会看到一个非常令人震惊的法国观点。没错。因为在德·克卢先生看来，他说一盎司巧克力所含的营养相当于一磅牛肉。一盎司巧克力？是的。我想要的不止一盎司。一盎司巧克力。但我的意思是，作为一个英国人，一个骄傲的英国人。是的，绝对是。你会同意巧克力比牛肉更有营养吗？
I suppose you could have them both, couldn't you? if you had a kind of Mexican mole, like a beef mole with a chocolate sauce. I guess you could. Anyway, so to continue why Monsieur de Calais was so enthused by chocolate. It is a dish so cheap as not to come above a penny. If tradesmen and artisans were once aware of it, there are few who would not take the advantage of so easy a method of breakfasting. Breakfasting. So agreeably. Yeah, breakfast the advantage of so easy a method of breakfasting. Breakfasting. Agreeably. Yeah, breakfasting.
我想你可以两者兼得，不是吗？如果你有一种墨西哥莫雷酱（mole），比如配巧克力酱的牛肉莫雷。我想你可以。总之，继续说为什么德·克卢先生对巧克力如此热衷。这道菜非常便宜，不到一便士。如果商人和工匠们一旦意识到这一点，很少有人会不利用这种如此简单的早餐方式。早餐。如此惬意。是的，早餐，利用这种如此简单的早餐方式。早餐。惬意。是的，早餐。
At so small a charge. And to be well supported till dinner time without taking any other sustenance, solid or liquid. I love hearing how Mr. Tichelou spoke. I think that's a real treat for the listeners. We were all about the authenticity. So there you have him promoting chocolate as the ultimate kind of breakfast food. Yes. That is, it's so sustaining that it will keep you going right the way up to supper.
花费如此之少。并且在晚餐前都能得到很好的支撑，无需摄入任何其他固体或液体食物。我喜欢听德·克卢先生说话的方式。我认为这对听众来说是一种真正的享受。我们追求的就是真实性。所以，这就是他将巧克力推崇为终极早餐食品。是的。也就是说，它非常耐饿，能让你一直撑到晚餐。
But he also recommends it as a medicine and suggests really to enhance the medicinal effects that you should add powders of millipedes, vapers, earthworms, and the livers and galls of eels. The gall of an eel. I'd love the gall of an eel. Where haven't people made that in chocolate form? I love chocolate, but I've never had millipedes or vipers or earthworms or the livers and ghouls of eels with it. But, I mean, maybe some kind of retro chocolate brand.
但他还建议将其作为药物，并提出为了真正增强药效，你应该加入马陆、蝰蛇、蚯蚓的粉末，以及鳗鱼的肝脏和胆汁。鳗鱼的胆。我真喜欢鳗鱼的胆。为什么人们没有把它做成巧克力形式呢？我喜欢巧克力，但我从未在里面加过马陆、蝰蛇、蚯蚓或鳗鱼的肝脏和胆汁。但是，我的意思是，也许可以有某种复古巧克力品牌。
Well, if only there were a retro chocolate brand who would do that. Now, Tom, we do love chocolate and the rest is history. And we are thrilled, aren't we? We're absolutely thrilled that we're able to do this episode in partnership with our friends at Cadbury. Because do you know what, Tom? It's their 200th anniversary this year. And, Donny, very important to emphasise that it is Cadbury and not Cadbury's, as I had always thought. Well, Theo, our producer, foolishly always calls it Cadbury's.
好吧，要是真有这样一个复古巧克力品牌就好了。现在，汤姆，我们确实热爱巧克力，而历史就是这样。我们非常激动，不是吗？我们非常激动能与我们的朋友吉百利（Cadbury）合作制作这一集。因为你知道吗，汤姆？今年是他们成立200周年。而且，多尼，非常重要的一点要强调，是Cadbury，而不是Cadbury's，正如我一直以为的那样。好吧，我们的制作人西奥（Theo）愚蠢地总是叫它Cadbury's。
But he's quite wrong, Tom. I know. Couldn't be wronger. He probably goes around talking about Boots the chemist rather than Boot the chemist, as we all know it is. Exactly, we all know it's Boot. Right, so Dominic, so chocolate. Yes. An amazing substance, but also an amazing history, right?
但他完全错了，汤姆。我知道。错得离谱。他可能到处说“Boots the chemist”（博姿药妆店），而不是像我们都知道的那样叫“Boot the chemist”。没错，我们都知道是Boot。好的，多米尼克，那么巧克力。是的。一种神奇的物质，但也有着神奇的历史，对吧？
A very rich, a very rich history. Rich. Rich and creamy. Rich and creamy history, Tom. Yes, I thought what we would do, because we have actually talked about doing a history of chocolates since about, you know, episode 20 of this podcast. Yeah, we have.
一段非常丰富，非常丰富的历史。丰富。丰富而丝滑。丰富而丝滑的历史，汤姆。是的，我想我们应该怎么做呢，因为我们实际上从这个播客的第20集左右就开始谈论要做一期巧克力的历史了。是的，我们谈过。
So I thought what we would do is in the first half, we talk about the deep history of chocolate. So the Olmecs, the Maya, the Aztecs, the Spaniards. Yeah, because we haven't talked about that for at least two months. Yes. And then in the second half, chocolate, Tom, there is no better window than a chocolate window into the story of modernity industrialization and victorian britain that is so
所以我认为我们应该在前半部分谈谈巧克力的深层历史。也就是奥尔梅克人、玛雅人、阿兹特克人、西班牙人。是的，因为我们至少有两个月没谈过这个了。是的。然后在后半部分，巧克力，汤姆，没有比巧克力更好的窗口来了解现代性、工业化和维多利亚时代的英国了，这真是
samurai so where are we beginning so should we i think we should begin with the olmecs so our listeners may know the olmecs as the fellows who made enormous heads didn't they stone heads yes in miso america and they almost look african don't they people who are into atlantis were very excited about these. They were indeed. I mean, obviously, they're not African. No. They're absolutely Olmec.
萨穆埃尔，那么我们从哪里开始呢？我想我们应该从奥尔梅克人开始。我们的听众可能知道奥尔梅克人是那些制作巨大头像的人，不是吗？石像头。是的，在美索美洲。它们看起来几乎像非洲人，不是吗？那些对亚特兰蒂斯感兴趣的人对这些非常兴奋。他们确实很兴奋。我的意思是，显然，他们不是非洲人。不。他们绝对是奥尔梅克人。
Very impressive, aren't they? You must have seen them in the museum in Mexico. In Mexico City, in the Anthropology Museum. Enormous kind of cuboid, exuding this incredible sense of power. Again, an Olmec head made of chocolate, Tom, would be a superb thing. That would keep you going. So they seem to have believed that cocoa, so they were grinding cocoa beans,
非常令人印象深刻，不是吗？你一定在墨西哥的博物馆里见过它们。在墨西哥城的国立人类学博物馆。巨大的立方体，散发着一种令人难以置信的力量感。再说一次，汤姆，用巧克力做的奥尔梅克头像会是一件极好的东西。那会让你充满活力。所以他们似乎相信可可，所以他们是在研磨可可豆，
which are obviously native to Mesoamerica. And which look like sheep s***, correct? Correct, because when English privateers later on found them, they would throw them into the sea, as we will discover. So the Olmecs, if you're interested in the Olmecs, there's a brilliant book for younger readers, actually, which talks about Olmecs' civilization at the beginning, called Adventure in Time, The Fall of the Aztecstecs but anyway that's by the by i just recommend that to the listeners the olmecs were the people who invented that bonkers ball game where you'd hit
这显然是美索美洲本土的。而且看起来像羊粪，对吧？没错，因为当英国私掠船后来发现它们时，他们会把它们扔进海里，正如我们稍后会发现的那样。所以奥尔梅克人，如果你对奥尔梅克人感兴趣，其实有一本很棒的给年轻读者的书，它在开头谈到了奥尔梅克文明，叫《时间冒险：阿兹特克人的陨落》，但无论如何，这只是顺便提一下，我只是向听众推荐那本书。奥尔梅克人是发明了那种疯狂球类游戏的人，你会用臀部击球，如果你输了，你就会被杀，你会被献祭。而且一些考古学家认为，当你输掉这个球类游戏时，你臀部不好，你输了比赛，你就会被献祭。在这个时刻，不知何故有可可或巧克力饮用。他们发现牺牲者的尸体旁有压碎的可可豆。但不是那种你踢完足球或打完板球然后去喝一杯的感觉。你不会从球场下来。喝一杯巧克力？喝一杯伯恩维尔（Bournville）。
the ball with your hips and if you lost you'd be killed and you exactly be sacrificed and some archaeologists think that when you lost this ball game you you had bad hips, you lost the ball game, you were sacrificed. There was somehow cocoa or chocolate drinking at this moment. There were crushed cocoa beans that they have found with the bodies of the sacrificial victims. But not kind of like you play a game of football or cricket and then go and have a pint. You wouldn't come off the ball court. Have a glass of chocolate? Have a Bourneville.
是的。不，我不这么认为。我想他们认为……更具神圣性。我想他们认为这是神圣的，是的。我的意思是，这其中很多都是推测。
Yeah. No, I don't think so. I think they thought... More sacral. I think they thought it was sacral, yeah. I mean, so much of this is supposition.
所以奥尔梅克人大约在公元前1500年，对吧？然后他们似乎把A，球类游戏，和B，研磨可可豆并制作这种苦味巧克力饮料的传统传了下去。
So the Olmec's about 1,500 BC, aren't they? And then they seem to have passed A, the ball game, and B, the tradition of grinding the cocoa beans and making this kind of bitter chocolatey drink.
因为此时它是苦的，不是吗？是的。我的意思是，这是关键所在。是的。所以我们不是在谈论那种。他们没有用糖来调味，例如。所以他们似乎把这个传给了玛雅人。
Because it is bitter at this point, isn't it? It is. I mean, that's the key thing. Yes. So we're not kind of talking. They're not flavouring it with sugar, for example. So they seem to have passed that to the Maya.
从我们所拥有的玛雅历史碎片中，我们感觉到他们会在仪式庆典和某种和平条约上喝这种巧克力。这会是社交性的吗？你会，你知道吗？是的。就像你说的，你知道，喝杯雪利酒？你会说，喝杯雪利酒。是的，我想这可能是对的。哦，太好了。谢谢。
And the sense we have from what fragments of kind of Maya history we have is that they would drink this chocolate in ritual celebrations and at sort of peace treaties. Would it be social? Would you kind of, you know? Yes. Like you say, you know, have a sherry? You'd say, have a sherry. Yes, I think that's probably right. Oh, lovely. Thank you.
然后是阿兹特克人，墨西加人（Mexicas），我想你会这样称呼他们，汤姆。是的，我会。他们绝对非常沉迷于巧克力。所以我们感觉到他们会在市场上，在特诺奇蒂特兰，在他们那里那个巨大的郊区市场里喝它。那里有很多可可豆。这会作为贡品带来吗？
And then the Aztecs, the Mexicas, I believe you would call them, Tom. Yes, I would. They were definitely well into their chocolate. So the sense we have is that they would have it in the market, in Tenochtitlan, in the great sort of suburban market they have there. There are lots of cacao beans. And would this be brought as tribute?
是的，我想他们是作为贡品带来的。而且更重要的是，他们很可能用这些豆子作为易货贸易，因为当然，他们没有货币。这是西班牙人注意到的事情之一。它们非常方便，不是吗？是的。我的意思是，一大堆豆子。这儿有些豆子。
Yes, I think they are bringing it as tribute. And what is more, they may well have used the beans as barter because, of course, they didn't have a currency. It's one of the things the Spaniards noticed. They're very convenient, aren't they? Yeah. I mean, a big pile of beans. There's some beans.
甚至比黄金还方便。是的。这当然是西班牙人来的目的。西班牙人是为了黄金而来。总之，我们不想讲阿兹特克人的陨落，但我在想，当西班牙人到达时，是的，他们是否意识到这些奇怪的豆子非常有价值，还是他们最初不感兴趣？不，我不认为他们对它们感兴趣，因为当然，它们对他们来说看起来没有价值。他们可能会想，好吧，这些人使用这些豆子，但
Even more convenient than gold. Yeah. Which, of course, is what the Spanish have come for. The Spanish have come for gold. Anyway, we don't want to do the fall of the Aztecs no but i'm just wondering when the spanish arrive yes do they pick up on the fact that actually these weird beans are incredibly valuable or are they initially not interested in no i don't think they are interested in them because of course they wouldn't seem valuable to they may think well these people use the beans but it's
并不是说他们对这些豆子感到兴奋，或者在他们之间交换它们之类的。而且再说一次，其他豆子，它们纯粹是为了喝吗？是的，你需要它们。再说一次，这其中有一种神圣的维度吗？很难说。这是一个非常好的问题。所以取决于你读的是谁的书，有一些记载，你知道，科尔特斯，例如，去和蒙特祖马住在一起。我们在1519年就此做了一千集节目。蒙特祖马是在给他喝热巧克力吗？一些历史学家在描绘这个场景时，让他们在一起喝某种热巧克力。
not like they're excited about the beans and swapping them among themselves or anything like that and again other beans are they purely for drink? Yeah, you will need them. Again, is there a kind of sacral dimension to it? So hard to say. That's a really good question. So depending who you read, there are some accounts, you know, Cortez, for example, goes to stay with Montezuma. We did a thousand episodes on this in 1519. And is Montezuma giving him hot chocolate to drink? Some historians, when they paint the scene, they have them drinking kind of hot chocolate together.
但如果它像你所说的那样具有神圣的意义，这种意义坦率地说已经传承了数千年，那么他们只是坐在那里，你知道，阿尔弗雷多·阿尔瓦拉多和吉尔，狂饮？该死的美味巧克力。大杯的巧克力。我不知道，而且我认为我们不可能
But if it has this, as you say, sacral significance, which has been passed down over, frankly, thousands of years, is it plausible that they're just sitting around, you know, Alfredo Alvarado and Gilles, quaffing? Bloody good chocolate. Mugs of chocolate. I don't know and I think we I think we can't possibly
知道，因为我们看到的很多东西都是以一种非常折射的方式。无论如何，汤姆，为了强调这一点，有宗教
know because so much of this we are seeing in a very kind of refracted way anyway Tom to hammer this home there is religious
有仪式维度，事实上，我应该已经提到这一点了。我知道你喜欢修士，不是吗？我们喜欢很多来自修士的记载。
there is a ritual dimension and in fact actually I should have mentioned this already I know you love a friar don't you we love a lot of accounts from friars
所以有一位名叫托里比奥·德·贝纳文特（Toribio de Benevente）的方济各会修士，他说他去了我们的老朋友特拉斯卡拉人（Tlaxcalans）那里，也就是特诺奇蒂特兰、墨西哥城的死对头。他说，在印第安城镇的诸圣节上，人们为死者做了许多祭品。有些是玉米，有些是毯子，有些是食物、面包、鸡肉，而他们用巧克力代替酒。
so there's a Franciscan friar called Toribio de Benevente and he says he went to our old friends, the Tlaxcalans, so the great rival of Tenochtitlan, Mexico City. And he says that on the Feast of All Souls in the Indian towns, many offerings are made for the dead. Some are for corn, others blankets, others food, bread, chickens, and in place of wine, they offer chocolate.
所以我猜这有两面性。一方面，它代替了酒，这表明它是一种社交饮料。但另一方面，它也在宗教中发挥作用。好吧，除非，我的意思是，酒在基督教中扮演着宗教角色，也许那里有某种回响。但显然巧克力对西班牙人没有任何神圣的含义。不。
So there's two sides to that, I guess. One is that it's in place of wine, which would suggest it is a social drink. But the other is that it also plays a part in a religious. Well, unless, I mean, wine plays a religious role in Christianity, perhaps there's an echo there. But obviously chocolate doesn't have any sacral connotations for the Spanish. No.
那么他们花了多长时间才弄清楚它们值得拥有呢？好吧，我们知道他们第一次把它带回西班牙的实例，或者我应该说是第一次有记录的实例，也许他们之前已经做过了。但我们有一个来源说是在1544年。所以那是多少？西班牙人第一次出现在墨西哥四分之一个世纪后，他们向国王菲利普二世赠送了可可种子。他是一个非常忧郁的人，不是吗，菲利普二世？我一点也不觉得他是个巧克力爱好者。在埃斯科里亚尔宫。
And so how long does it take them to kind of work out that they're worth having? Well, we know when the first instance of them bringing it back to Spain is, or the first recorded instance, I should say, maybe they've done it beforehand. But we have a source that says it's 1544. So what's that? Quarter of a century after the Spanish had first pitched up in Mexico, and they present a gift of cacao seeds to King Philip II. He's a very gloomy man, isn't he, Philip II? I don't see him as a chocolate man at all. In the Escorial.
在埃斯科里亚尔宫，没错。现在，历史学家认为这可能不是第一次。牧师可能带过，商人等等。好吧，我想这就像老印度手带回咖喱的味道一样。所以也许老墨西哥人必须在马德里见面喝巧克力。他们对巧克力的问题，当然是，我的意思是，强调这一点很重要，它非常苦。磨碎的东西。
In the Escorial, exactly. Now, historians think this probably wasn't the very first time. Priests might have brought about merchants and so on. Well, I guess it would be like old India hands bringing back a taste of a curry. So maybe old Mexico has to meet up in Madrid for chocolate. The issue they have with chocolate, of course, is that it is, I mean, it's important to stress this point, it's very bitter. The ground up stuff.
但它给了你咖啡因的冲击。是的，我想它确实给了你冲击。所以有一个叫吉罗拉莫·本佐尼（Girolamo Benzoni）的意大利人，在1575年，他对巧克力非常不满。他去了墨西哥，四处游荡，他说，我不会用意大利口音说。他说，它看起来更，我会说，它看起来更像是猪喝的饮料。所以他说他在那里待了一年，他不想喝任何巧克力。每当他经过一个定居点，就会有人出来说，你知道，喝杯巧克力，喝杯巧克力。
But it's giving you a caffeine hit. Yes, I guess it is giving you a hit. So there's an Italian guy called Girolamo Benzoni, and in 1575, he was very disobliging about chocolate. He went to Mexico and sort of roamed around a bit, and he said, I won't do it in an Italian accent. He said, it seemed more, I will, it seemed more a drink for pigs. So he says he was there for a year and he didn't want to drink any. Whenever he went past a settlement, somebody would come out and say, you know, have a chocolate, have a chocolate.
当他拒绝时，他们会感到惊讶。然后他们会笑着走开。嘲笑他的巧克力白痴行为。但他找不到酒，所以最终他妥协了，开始喝巧克力。他说他非常失望。所以当它到达西班牙时，人们在那时已经开始加糖了。我的意思是，你和我吃的巧克力，汤姆，显然已经加了糖。所以用糖？他们在使用糖。
They would be amazed when he refused it. And they would go away laughing. Laughing at him because of his chocolate. Idiocy. But he couldn't find wine, so eventually he cracked and started drinking chocolate. And he said he was very disappointed. So when it gets to Spain, people by that point are sweetening it already. I mean, the chocolate that you and I eat, Tom, has been sweetened, obviously. So with sugar? They are using sugar.
他们在使用糖。他们在使用蜂蜜。他们在使用糖。他们在使用糖，他们在使用蜂蜜，他们在使用香草。当然，西班牙人已经在加那利群岛生产糖很长一段时间了。然后他们也把糖带到了加勒比海。但还有一个有趣的宗教维度，汤姆。你看到了吗？我知道你喜欢宗教维度。
They're using sugar. They're using honey. And they're using sugar. They're using sugar, they're using honey, and they're using vanilla. And of course, the Spanish have already been producing sugar for some considerable time on the Canary Islands. And then they've taken sugar to the Caribbean as well. But there is also an interesting religious dimension, Tom. Have you seen this? I know you love a religious dimension.
好吧，你认为每件事都有宗教维度。不，我没有。我不知道还有宗教维度。你不知道吗？不。所以问题，我的意思是，我不知道还有宗教维度。你不知道吗？不。所以问题，我的意思是，有多个问题，但如果我们直奔主题，第一个问题是如果墨西加人在他们的仪式中使用它。
Well, you think everything has a religious dimension. No, I don't. I had no idea that there was a religious dimension. Did you not? No. So the issue, I mean,. I had no idea that there was a religious dimension. Did you not? No. So the issue, I mean, there are multiple issues, but if we sort of cut to the chase, issue number one is if the Mexica have been using it in their rituals.
哦，它是偶像崇拜吗？它是偶像崇拜吗？喝巧克力是不好的形式吗？看起来多米尼克修会非常讨厌巧克力。所以他们实际上据称纠缠教皇去取缔它。去禁止它？是的，去禁止巧克力。显然在1569年，教皇庇护五世喝了一些巧克力，他说，我引用，太恶心了，他决定没有必要禁止它。
Oh, is it idolatrous? Is it idolatrous? Is it bad form to be drinking chocolate? And it seems that the Dominicans are very down on chocolate. So they actually supposedly pester the Pope to outlaw it. To ban it? Yeah, to ban chocolate. And apparently in 1569, Pope Pius V drank some chocolate, and he said it was, and I quote, so foul he decided there was no need to ban it.
好吧。所以同样，不是吉百利的粉丝。不是吉百利的粉丝。现在第二个辩论是里希·苏纳克（Rishi Sunak）的一个大问题。所以你可能读过，汤姆，里希·苏纳克禁食。他确实禁食。是的，他整个周一都禁食，不是吗？是的。
Right. So again, not a friend of Cadbury. Not a friend of Cadbury. Now the second debate is a big issue for Rishi Sunak. So you may have read, Tom, Rishi Sunak fasts. He does. Yeah, he fasts all Monday, doesn't he? Yeah.
周日晚上到周二早上五点。打破禁食的奇怪时间，但无论如何，给你。他有很多事要做。他起得很早。像你一样。总之，里希·苏纳克对巧克力的问题是他喝茶和咖啡。他可以那样做。他能喝巧克力吗？
Sunday night at five o'clock on Tuesday morning. Strange time to break a fast, but anyway, there you go. He's got a lot to do. He gets up early. Like you. Anyway, the problem for Rishi Sunak with chocolate is he drinks tea and coffee. He can do that. Could he drink chocolate?
你的答案是什么？是的，我会这么说。好吧，你会同意一些修士的观点，但不同意另一些。所以你会不同意安东尼奥·德·莱昂·皮内洛（Antonio de Leon Pinelo），他在1636年写了一本书，标题很吸引人，《道德问题：巧克力是否打破教会禁食》（Question Moral, Si il cioccolate che parante è l'euno ecclesiastico），正如我们所有的听众都知道的那样，是巧克力是否打破教会禁食？一个道德问题。他认为打破了。他认为打破了。他说，这显然是食物。这不是饮料。
What would your answer be there? Yeah, I'd say so. Well, you would agree with some friars, but not others. So you would disagree with Antonio de Leon Pinelo, who in 1636 wrote a book with the catchy title, Question Moral, Si il cioccolate che parante è l'euno ecclesiastico, which is all our listeners will know, is does chocolate break an ecclesiastical fast? A moral question. And he thought it did. He thought it did. He said, this is patently a food. This is no drink.
是因为它很稠吗？也许吧。我不知道。也许他只是不喜欢巧克力，他想阻止人们喝它。他想贬低它。另一个人，托马斯·奥塔多（Tomas Otado），来自我读到的一个叫“教士常规小会”（Clerics' Regular Minor）的教团。你认识他们吗？不，我从来没听说过。
Is that because it's very thick? Maybe so. I don't know. Maybe he just didn't like chocolate and he wanted to stop people drinking it. He wanted to diss it. A different man, Tomas Otado, who came from an order I read called the Clerics' Regular Minor. Do you know them? No, I've never heard of them.
他写了另一本书叫《巧克力与烟草，教会与自然禁食》（Cioccolati e Tabacco, Auno Ecclesiastico e Natural）。所以他支持。是的。耶稣会士也参与了。他们找了一位红衣主教。他写了一份16页的意见书。人们怎么能写这么多关于巧克力的东西？
He wrote another book called Cioccolati e Tabacco, Auno Ecclesiastico e Natural. So he's in favour. Yeah. The Jesuits got involved. They got a cardinal. He wrote a 16-page opinion. How are people writing so much about chocolate?
这个人，弗朗切斯科·玛丽亚·布兰卡乔（Francesco Maria Brancaccio）红衣主教，他写了一篇叫《论巧克力饮料》（De Chocolatis Potu）的文章，关于巧克力的使用。没错。他说，哦，这是一种饮料。拜托，这是一种饮料。然后令人难以置信的是，教皇亚历山大七世，1666年，
This guy, Cardinal Francesco Maria Brancaccio, he wrote a thing called De Chocolatis Potu, on the use of chocolate. Right. He said, oh, it's a drink. Come on, it's a drink. And then unbelievably, the Pope, Alexander VII, 1666,
他用拉丁语宣布。你想读拉丁语吗，汤姆？Liquidum non frangit jejunum（液体不打破禁食）。是的，所以他明确说这是一种液体。好吧，很高兴知道在反宗教改革期间，这些问题主导了天主教欧洲最优秀的大脑。在三十年战争时代。
he pronounced in Latin. Do you want to read the Latin, Tom? Liquidum non frangit jejunum. Liquids do not break the fast. Yeah, so he said definitely a liquid. Well, it's brilliant to know that during the Counter-Reformation, these questions are dominating the finest brains in Catholic Europe. During the age of the Thirty Years' War.
总之，西班牙人会把巧克力作为礼物送给其他欧洲宫廷。他们会说，看看这种非凡的饮料。这和咖啡是同时传播的。是的，完全正确。所以这是一种感觉，它们在正面交锋，哪个更时尚，咖啡还是巧克力？我认为很多人对巧克力非常怀疑。法国人显然非常怀疑。
So anyway, the Spanish would give chocolate to other European courts as a gift. They would say, look at this extraordinary drink. And this is spreading at the same time as coffee. Yes, exactly so. So it's the sense that they're going head to head, which is more fashionable, coffee or chocolate? I think a lot of people are very suspicious of chocolate. The French, apparently, are very suspicious.
他们为什么怀疑？苦。它是苦的，汤姆。苦。所以他们不担心邪恶的、异教的、偶像崇拜的含义。还有禁食的问题，我想。苏纳克问题。现在，英国人是19世纪巧克力故事中的大英雄，当然，正如我们稍后会发现的那样。
And why are they suspicious? Bitter. It's bitter, Tom. Bitter. So they're not worried about the sinister, pagan, idolatrous connotations. And also the issue of the fast, I suppose. The Sunak issue. Now, the English are the great heroes of the story of chocolate in the 19th century, of course, as we would discover.
但在现阶段，我们是迟到的采用者，汤姆。没错。这是因为每次，比如，弗朗西斯·德雷克和所有小伙子们出去捕获西班牙船只。是的。他们寻找黄金，他们冲上一艘船，他们发现的只有可可豆。这就是英国人觉得可可豆，因为它们看起来像羊粪，不值得保留，所以他们就把它们扔进海里。
But at this stage, we are very late adopters, Tom. Right. And this is because every time, say, Francis Drake and all the lads are out capturing Spanish ships. Yes. And they're looking for gold and they pile onto a ship and all they find are cocoa beans. And this is where the English feeling that cocoa beans, because they look like sheep droppings, are not worth keeping and so they just dump them in the sea.
是的，他们只是想，西班牙人在搞什么鬼？在大西洋上航行。尽管事实上到这个时候，可可豆一定值很多钱。你会这么认为，是的。但有一个故事，当然在1579年，有私掠船把可可豆扔到海里的故事。然后在1648年，一位编年史家写道，
Yeah, they just think, what are the Spanish up to? Sailing around the Atlantic. Despite the fact that by this point, actually, cocoa beans must be worth quite a lot. You would assume so, yeah. But there is a story, certainly in 1579, there's the story of privateers throwing the cocoa beans overboard. And then in 1648, a chronicler writes and says,
荷兰人也这样做。所以也许是新教徒的事情，也许是新教徒的怀疑。我的意思是，也许。一种虔诚的怀疑。是的，所有这些红衣主教和神学家，天主教神学家一直在宣布巧克力，而荷兰人需要说，听着，这是教皇的胡言乱语。但显然大的转折点是1655年，
the Dutch do this. So maybe a Protestant thing, maybe a Protestant suspicion. I mean, maybe. A godly suspicion. Yeah, all these cardinals and theologians, Catholic theologians have been pronouncing chocolate, and the Dutch need to say, listen, this is papist nonsense. But obviously the big turning point is 1655,
那是克伦威尔从西班牙人手中夺取牙买加的时候。因为，多米尼克……是的。大概，你需要一定数量的劳动力……没错，确实。……来收获这些东西，对吧？没错。这些劳动力从哪里来？
and that is when Cromwell captures Jamaica from the Spanish. Because, Dominic... Yes. Presumably, you need a certain supply of labour... Right, exactly. ...to harvest this stuff, right? Exactly. Where is this labour coming from?
所以此时，发生了什么，听过关于克里斯托弗·哥伦布剧集的人会记得，随着伊斯帕尼奥拉岛等地以及加勒比海所有泰诺人的死亡，西班牙人开始运来非洲奴隶，这种做法他们在加那利群岛就已经开始了。到1650年代，加勒比海的非洲奴隶人口大约占总人口的80%？而且很多这些岛屿实际上已经变成了巨大的种植园。
So at this point, what has happened is, people who listen to episodes about Christopher Columbus will recall that with the deaths of all the Taino people on Hispaniola and so on, and in the Caribbean, the Spanish started bringing over African slaves and practice they had originated in the Canary Islands. And by the 1650s, the African slave population of the Caribbean is what, about 80% of the whole? And a lot of these islands have effectively been turned into enormous plantations.
糖，最著名，但也用于种植可可。糖和可可之间的平衡是什么？糖是远为……好的。所以我们做了一集，不是吗，关于本杰明·莱（Benjamin Lay），我们谈到了17世纪末、18世纪种植园的生活是什么样的。是的。所以一定要听那一集。
Sugar, most famously, but also for growing cocoa. And what's the balance between sugar and cocoa? Sugar is by far the more... Okay. So we did an episode, didn't we, on Benjamin Lay, where we talked about what life was like in the plantations in the late 17th, 18th century. Yes. So do listen to that.
所以巧克力构成了那种三角贸易的一部分。英国人在1655年占领了牙买加，所以他们显然在巧克力生意上投入更多，正如他们所说。我们在1657年得到了第一次有记录的提及，仅仅两年后。那是在克伦威尔征服牙买加之后。没错。是否有一种感觉，克伦威尔派出了这支伟大的远征队去牙买加，这基本上是他们得到的唯一东西。
So chocolate forms part of that kind of triangular trade. The English have taken Jamaica in 1655, so then they obviously got more invested in the chocolate business, as it were. We get our first recorded mention in 1657, just two years later. And that's in the wake of the Cromwellian conquest of Jamaica. Exactly. And is there a sense that Cromwell sent this great expedition to Jamaica, it's basically the only thing that they've got.
是的。这确实是一场灾难。你认为英联邦方面是否有一种感觉，他们需要大肆宣传这些收益？是的，收益。所以，你知道，好吧，我们没有得到任何黄金，但我们得到了这些不可思议的羊粪。我不确定这一点。
Yes. It's really been a bit of a disaster. And do you think there's a kind of feeling on the part of the Commonwealth that they need to hype up the gains? Yeah, the gains. So, you know, okay, we haven't got any gold, but we have got this incredible sheep droppings. I'm not sure about that.
我不认为这是从高层指挥的。我认为这只是……它开始渗透进来，如果这不是太多的基于咖啡的隐喻的话。总之，《公共广告商》（Public Advertiser），1657年，一则广告说，在皇后门巷（Queensgate Alley）的一位法国人家里，
I don't think it's directed from on high. I think it's just... It's starting to kind of come in. Yeah, it's just sort of to percolate in, if that's not too much of a coffee-based metaphor. So anyway, the public advertiser, 1657, an advertisement says, at a Frenchman's house in Queensgate Alley,
其实有趣的是那是一位法国人的家，有一种极好的西印度饮料叫巧克力出售，在那里你可以随时以合理的价格买到。而且佩皮斯（Peeps）喝它吗？佩皮斯确实喝它。佩皮斯在1664年喝了它，大约中午，和佩特专员（Commissioner Pett）出去，他和我都进了一家咖啡馆喝巧克力（giocolatte）。非常好，他说。
actually interesting that it's a Frenchman's house, is an excellent West India drink called chocolate to be sold, where you may have it ready at any time at reasonable rates. And doesn't Peeps drink it? Peeps does drink it. Peeps drinks it in 1664, about noon, out with Commissioner Pett, and he and I into a coffee house to drink giocolatte. Very good, he says.
哦，那很好。是的，那很可爱。而且你在那个时候得到了我们的第一个食谱，我们的第一个英国食谱，1650年代。他们给它调味，因为它太苦了。所以食谱说加糖。这其实是一个非常奇怪的食谱。长红辣椒、丁香、茴香籽、杏仁、坚果、橙花水、面粉和可可。喝得越热越好，食谱作者说。
Oh, that's nice. Yeah, that's lovely. And you get our first recipe, our first English recipe about this time, 1650s. They're flavouring it because it is so bitter. So the recipe says put in sugar. It's a very strange recipe, actually. A long red pepper, cloves, anise seed, almonds, nuts, orange water, flour and cacao. The hotter it is drunk, the better it is, says the recipe's author.
所以此时它绝对还是一种饮料。他们没有在做巧克力棒。不，它完全是，你不能做巧克力棒。我们稍后会谈到你怎么做巧克力棒。它完全是一种饮料。它非常昂贵。所以从加勒比海进口的豆子有很高的进口税。所以大约每磅50便士，这是一大笔钱。所以一位历史学家做了计算。一个熟练的工匠要买一磅可可豆需要一周的工作。你买它的方式，你会买磨碎的。这有点像你买磨碎的咖啡。它会被压成一小块，用纸包着。而且因为它太贵了，这些小块非常小。我的意思是，它们只有几盎司。它们一点也不大，但到17世纪末，你有了巧克力屋
So it's still absolutely, at this point, a drink. They're not kind of making chocolate bars. No, it's totally, you can't make a chocolate bar. And we'll get onto how you make a chocolate bar in due course. It's totally a drink. It is very expensive. So there's high import duties on the beans that come from the Caribbean. So about 50 pence per pound, which is a lot of money. So one historian's done the calculation. That's a week's work for a skilled tradesman to buy a pound of cocoa beans. And the way you would buy it, you would buy it ground. It's a bit like you're buying ground coffee. And it would be sort of pressed into a little cake wrapped in paper. And because it's so expensive, these cakes are tiny. I mean, they're a couple of ounces. They're not big at at all but by the late 17th century you have chocolate houses
最著名的是怀特夫人巧克力屋（Mrs White's chocolate house），它在圣詹姆斯。我们的一些听众会听说过最古老的圣詹姆斯绅士俱乐部，也就是怀特俱乐部（White's），就是那个。哦，对了，怀特俱乐部，我想大卫·卡梅伦的……是的，所有的服务员都叫乔治，是的，类似那样。而且他们有这些博彩书，布莱克布鲁克（Blackbrook's）和其他俱乐部也有，上面有威灵顿公爵或其他什么人下的有趣的赌注。
and the most famous one is mrs white's cocoa house or mrs white's chocolate house which is in st james's and some of our listeners will have heard of the oldest of all st james's gentlemen's clubs which is white that's what it is oh right white's the club which i think david cameron's yes and all the all the waiters are called george yes something like that and they have one of these White's. That's what it is. Oh, right. White's, the club, which I think David Cameron's father resigned from. I think all the waiters are called George. Yeah, something like that. And they have one of these betting books that Blackbrook's and other clubs have with amusing bets placed by the Duke of Wellington or something.
进化气球。是的，没错。所以怀特俱乐部，它是一家巧克力店。哦，太棒了。而且它臭名昭著，显然是因为浪子们会去那里，在他们的巧克力、水果和坚果上进行淫秽的谈话。
Evolving balloons. Yes, exactly. So White's was, it was a chocolate shop. Oh, brilliant. And it was notorious, apparently apparently because rakes would go and have lewd conversations over their chocolate fruit and nut
拜托，所以该死，所以丹尼尔·笛福（Daniel Defoe），他说父亲应该警告他们的女儿关于巧克力屋里发生的淫乱谈话的邪恶。哇，所以是的，小心。所以这很有趣。
please so damn your eyes so Daniel Defoe he said fathers should warn their daughters of the evils
巧克力显然扮演了多种角色。所以有一件事它绝对不是，绝对不是给孩子喝的。没有提到……好吧，不，因为如果它与浪子和淫乱联系在一起……没错，还有偶像崇拜。好吧，到这个时候大概不是偶像崇拜了。
of promiscuous conversations that take place in chocolate houses wow so yeah watch out so this is interesting.
不，不，不。但浪子和淫乱。还有地狱火俱乐部之类的东西。没错。这种名声持续了很长时间，即它是一种催情剂的想法。殖民地，例如，保留了这一点。所以《弗吉尼亚年鉴》（Virginia Almanac），1770年，
Chocolate clearly plays multiple roles. So one thing it's not, it's absolutely not, is for children. There's no mention of... Well, no, because if it's associated with rakes and promiscuity... Right, and idolatry. Well, presumably not idolatry by this point.
警告女性要特别小心如何处理浪漫小说、巧克力、小说之类的东西，特别是在春天，它说。这些都是煽动者，非常危险。这就是巧克力与浪漫联系起来的原因吗？像Flake巧克力棒一样，汤姆。Flake，我的意思是，这是一种情人节巧克力，那种东西。我想是吧，是的。
No, no, no. But rakes and promiscuity. But hellfire clubs and things. Exactly. And this reputation lasts quite a long time, the idea that it's an aphrodisiac. The colonies, for example, preserve this. So the Virginia Almanac, 1770,
巧克力被认为是色情的，不是吗？是的。人们不认为茶或咖啡是色情的。不。所以大茶和大咖啡。他们错过了。他们错过了。所以它是一种催情剂。
warns the fair sex to be in a particular manner careful how they meddle with romances, chocolate, novels and the like, especially in the spring, it says. These are all inflamers and very dangerous. And is that where the kind of association of chocolate with romance comes from? Like a flake, Tom. The flake, I mean, it's kind of Valentine's chocolates, that kind of thing. I guess so, yeah.
奇怪的是，它也是一种早餐饮料。1796年，一个叫约翰·珀金斯（John Perkins）的人说，从最高层到最低层的人的普通早餐是茶、咖啡或巧克力。有一本食谱，《伊斯兰韧性》（Islam Resilience），1814年。玛丽亚·伦德尔（Maria Rundell），《国内烹饪新系统》。她说可可，一种清淡健康的早餐。她有这个食谱。你基本上做一个巧克力糖浆，你可以储存它长达一周，然后你把它加到牛奶里
Chocolate is regarded as erotic, isn't it? Yeah. People don't regard tea or coffee as erotic. No. So big tea and big coffee. They've missed out. They have missed out. So it's an aphrodisiac.
然后你做一大杯热巧克力，一碗热巧克力，那就是你的早餐。那就是你的早餐。你知道吗？当我在1980年代进行法国交换生项目时，我们早餐都喝碗装的巧克力。德·克卢先生会很高兴知道这一点。
Bizarrely, it's also a breakfast drink. In 1796, a guy called John Perkins said the general breakfast to people from the highest to the lowest is tea, coffee or chocolate. There's a cookbook, Islam Resilience, 1814. Maria Rundell, a new system of domestic cookery. She says cocoa, a light and wholesome breakfast. She has this recipe. You make basically a chocolate syrup and you can store it for up to a week and you add it to milk
但那家的法国人，他早餐喝啤酒。没错。而我们都喝热巧克力。另一件事，汤姆，是它有药用价值。所以我认为你在开头提到了，不是吗，把它和鳗鱼胆和鳗鱼肝混合。蝰蛇和蚯蚓。
and then you make a big hot chocolate, bowl of hot chocolate, and that's your breakfast. That's your breakfast. And do you know what? When I did my French exchange in the 1980s, we all drank bowls of chocolate at breakfast. Monsieur de Calais would be thrilled to know that.
蝰蛇。我的意思是，这在18世纪非常普遍。药房会卖巧克力。你进去，你知道，咳嗽，宿醉，你说你的性欲
But the Frenchman of the house, he drank beer at breakfast. Right. And we all drank hot chocolate. The other thing, Tom, is it's medicinal. So I think you mentioned at the beginning, didn't you, mixing it with eel's gall and eel's livers. Vipers and earthworms.
状况不佳，药剂师会说，没有什么比鳗鱼胆更能让血液流动了。本杰明·富兰克林显然推荐巧克力作为治疗
Vipers. I mean, that is very common in the 18th century. Apothecary shops would sell chocolate. You went in with you know a cough a hangover you said your libido
天花的药物。这就是导致税收叛乱的那种白痴行为。它绝对是。而托马斯·杰斐逊，不是《历史余韵》的朋友，正如记录在案的那样，他给我们的老朋友约翰·亚当斯写了一封信。哦，是的。他说……
was in poor shape apothecary would say There's nothing like a ghoul of eel to get the blood coursing. Benjamin Franklin apparently recommended chocolate as a cure
他说了什么？他有那种美国殖民者的声音。他说……你好，我的爱人。巧克力在健康和营养方面的优越性，很快就会让它在美国取代茶和咖啡，就像它在西班牙那样。好吧，那不是真的，是吗？所以，嗯，托马斯·杰斐逊，是的，也相信在美国西部有乳齿象存在，而且他
for smallpox. That's the kind of idiocy that leads to tax rebellions. It absolutely is. And Thomas Jefferson, not a friend of the rest of his history, as is on record, he wrote a letter to our old friend John Adams. Oh, yeah. And he said...
在这一点上也错了。关于几乎所有事情都错了，我想我会说几乎是杰斐逊。好吧，我们进行了一半了，汤姆，我认为我们可以从中得出的伟大结论，最重要的事情是巧克力是一种饮料。是的。此时没有人吃巧克力。但也因为它有多么异国情调。它是异国情调的。
What did he say? He had this American colonial voice. He said... Hello, my lover. The superiority of chocolate, both for health and nourishment, will soon give it the preference over tea and coffee in america which it has in spain well that's not true is it so um thomas jefferson yeah also believed that out in the west of america there were mastodons to be found and he
它是令人兴奋的。它是色情的。它是药用的。它是一种很棒的早餐食品。它是一种早餐饮料。是的。它是一种早餐饮料。它不是一种早餐食品。
was wrong about that as well wrong about almost everything i think i'd say it's almost jefferson right we're halfway through tom and i think the great conclusion we can draw from this, the overriding thing is that chocolate is a drink. Yes. Nobody has eaten chocolate at this point. But also how exotic it is. It's exotic.
你在那里暴露了自己。但对你来说好消息是这一切即将改变。这实际上是伟大的转折之一。历史上最令人震惊的革命之一。因为在后半部分，汤姆，巧克力将成为一种食物。好吧，我们正在接近1824年吉百利成立的那个重要日期。非常好。
It's exciting. It's erotic. It's medicinal. It's a great breakfast food. It's a breakfast drink. Yes. It's a breakfast drink. It's not a breakfast food.
所以休息后，我们将谈到这一点。历史上伟大的时刻之一。谈到这一点。等不及了。历史上伟大的时刻之一。等不及了。欢迎回到《历史余韵》。我们正在谈论巧克力的历史，迄今为止是一种液体，但很快就会变成一块。这公平吗？
You've betrayed yourself there. But the good news for you is that all this is about to change. It's one of the great turnarounds, actually. One of the most astonishing revolutions in history. Because in the second half, Tom, chocolate will become a food. Well, we're approaching that momentous date of 1824 when Cadbury was founded. Very good.
这很公平。因为我们现在基本上接近一波贵格会教徒。而且我们被一家以其中一人命名的公司赞助，在我们进入一波类别之前。或者1650年代，真的。好吧，1654年是一个叫乔治·福克斯（George Fox）的人出生的日期。他是一个你心中非常亲近的人，不是吗？好吧，所以我们在《历史余韵》中非常热衷于贵格会教徒。所以本杰明·莱是一位贵格会教徒。还有玛丽·费舍尔（Mary Fisher），她是最近被加冕的历史爱情爱尔兰女王，不是吗？她是。
So after the break, we will get on to that. One of the great moments in history. on to that. Can't wait. One of the great moments in history. Can't wait. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are talking about the history of chocolate, hitherto a liquid, but soon to become a bar. Would that be fair?
和托尼·本（Tony Benn）一起。所以她也是一位贵格会教徒。正如你所说，这一切都始于这个叫乔治·福克斯的人，他出生于1624年。但贵格会运动直到1650年代才真正开始起飞。没错。所以和英国人……占领牙买加的同一个十年。占领牙买加。
That is fair. Because we are now approaching basically a wave of Quakers. And we're being sponsored by a company that is named after one before we get onto a wave of categories. Or 1650s, really. Well, 1654 is the date that a fellow called George Fox was born. He's a man very dear to your heart, isn't he? Well, so we're very keen on Quakers on the rest of history. So Benjamin Lay was a Quaker. And Mary Fisher, who was the most recently crowned queen of historical love Ireland, wasn't she? She was.
巧克力的岁月。但在英国，这是一个宗教动荡的时期。国王被处决了。克伦威尔掌权。而且有一种宗教意见的自由。克伦威尔非常热衷于此。而贵格会教徒本质上是，他们是一种非常激进的新教教派。
With Tony Benn. So she was a Quaker as well. And it all kicks off, as you say, with this guy, George Fox, who is born in 1624. But the Quaker movement doesn't really start kind of taking wing until the 1650s. Right. So the same decade that the English... Take Jamaica. Take Jamaica.
他们是在寻找他们内心的光。当他们感觉到这种光降临在他们身上时，有一种狂喜、颤抖、战栗、咆哮、口吐白沫。所以场景就像我们《历史余韵》俱乐部聚会中的一个。它绝对是。所以“贵格会”（Quaker，意为颤抖者）这个名字最初是一种侮辱，但像许多其他事情一样，它变成了一种骄傲的象征。这和帽子有关。他们不会摘下帽子。他们不会摘下帽子，因为他们是，而且女性拒绝行屈膝礼。所以它变成了一种骄傲的象征。这和帽子有关。他们不会摘下帽子。他们不会摘下帽子，因为他们是，
The years of chocolate. But back in England, it's a period of religious turmoil. The king's been executed. Cromwell is in charge. And there is kind of freedom of religious opinion. Cromwell is very keen on that. And the Quakers essentially are, they're a kind of very radical Protestant sect.
而且女性拒绝行屈膝礼。所以有一个非常感人的故事，亚历克·赖里（Alec Ryrie）在他关于新教徒的精彩著作中讲述了。有一个女仆在一位贵族餐桌旁侍候。所有的领主和浪子都在嘲笑她不肯行屈膝礼的事实。他们给她20英镑让她行屈膝礼。
They are kind of seeking the light within them. And when they feel this light descend on them, there's kind of ecstatic, shaking, trembling, roaring, foaming at the mouth. So the scenes in one of our Restless History Club get-togethers. It absolutely is. And so the name Quaker begins as an insult, but like so many other things, it becomes a kind of badge of pride. There's something to do with hats. They won't take their hats off. They won't take their hats off because they are, and women refuse to curtsy. So it becomes a kind of badge of pride. There's something to do with hats. They won't take their hats off. They won't take their hats off because they are,
他们是在寻找内心的光。当他们感受到这道光降临时，会产生一种狂喜、颤抖、战栗、咆哮、口吐白沫的状态。这就是我们“不安分历史俱乐部”聚会中的场景。确实如此。因此，“贵格会”这个名字最初是一种侮辱，但就像许多其他事物一样，它后来变成了一种荣誉的象征。这与帽子有关。他们拒绝脱帽。他们拒绝脱帽是因为他们，而且女性拒绝行屈膝礼。所以它变成了一种荣誉的象征。这与帽子有关。他们拒绝脱帽。他们拒绝脱帽是因为他们，
and women refuse to curtsy. So there's a kind of very moving story, which Alec Ryrie in his wonderful book on Protestants tells. There's a servant girl who is in attendance at a kind of aristocrat's table. And all the lords and rakes are laughing at the fact that she won't curtsy. And they offer her 20 pounds to curtsy.
而且女性拒绝行屈膝礼。亚历克·赖里（Alec Ryrie）在他那本关于新教徒的精彩著作中讲述了一个非常感人的故事。有一位女仆在一位贵族的餐桌旁侍奉。所有的领主和浪子都在嘲笑她拒绝行屈膝礼。他们出价20英镑让她行屈膝礼。
And she replied that even if he offered her his entire estate, I durst not do it for all honour belongeth to God. And so in that principle, there is no titles, no clergy, absolute sense of human equality, gender equality, and a kind of sobriety. And in the 1650s, this is pushed to very radical extremes, so much so that Quaker evangelists will appear in marketplaces and take their clothes off, like Adam, going back to the kind of the lost innocence that prevailed in the Garden of Eden before the fall.
她回答说，即使他把整个庄园都给她，我也不敢这样做，因为所有的荣耀都属于上帝。因此，在这一原则下，没有头衔，没有神职人员，有着绝对的人类平等、性别平等和一种清醒的意识。在17世纪50年代，这种思想被推向了非常激进的极端，以至于贵格会的传教士会出现在市场上，像亚当一样脱掉衣服，回归到伊甸园堕落前那种失落的纯真状态。
But in the wake of that kind of convulsive decade, Quakers become, well, I suppose, more sober. I was about to say, later Quakers are the very last people who would take their clothes off in public, aren't they? Yeah, they are. So that kind of radical tradition tends to fade. But the absolute commitment to gender equality and social equality, pacifism. Philanthropy. Philanthropy.
但在那十年动荡之后，贵格会教徒变得，嗯，我想，更加清醒了。我正想说，后来的贵格会教徒是最后才会当众脱衣服的人，不是吗？是的，他们确实是。所以那种激进的传统往往会逐渐消失。但他们对性别平等、社会平等、和平主义和慈善事业的绝对承诺却保留了下来。慈善。慈善。
So I think to modernise, they seem very kind of attractive, the Christian sect. They're driving modernity aren't they so in the 18th century an age of extraordinary change and then the early 19th century quakers are in the forefront of that so it's quakers people from shropshire will be delighted to hear me mention that abraham darby is a quaker from shropshire and it's a darby family that's responsible for the world's first iron bridge tom where is that dominic so that's in iron bridge and shropshire. It's one of the great tourist destinations in all the world. The Stockton-Darlington Railway, which we talked about in our railways episode with Dan Jackson.
所以我认为，从现代化的角度来看，这个基督教派别似乎非常有吸引力。他们正在推动现代化，不是吗？所以在18世纪这个非凡变革的时代，以及19世纪早期，贵格会教徒都处于最前沿。所以，来自什罗普郡的人听到我提到亚伯拉罕·达比是什罗普郡的贵格会教徒一定会很高兴，正是达比家族负责建造了世界上第一座铁桥。汤姆，那座桥在哪里？多米尼克，那是在什罗普郡的铁桥镇。它是世界上最伟大的旅游目的地之一。斯托克顿-达灵顿铁路，我们在和丹·杰克逊的铁路那一集中谈到过。
That was owned by a Quaker. It's not Stonehenge, is it? Josiah Wedwood. Yes, great potter. Potter was a Quaker. And Quakers are very, very active in trade and in banking. I think because they've been pushed to the margins, haven't they, of English life. So a little bit like Jews as well.
那是属于一个贵格会教徒的。那不是巨石阵，对吧？约赛亚·韦奇伍德。是的，伟大的陶艺家。陶艺家也是贵格会教徒。贵格会教徒在贸易和银行业非常非常活跃。我想是因为他们被挤到了英国生活的边缘，不是吗？所以有点像犹太人。
Like Jews and Armenians. And there's a lot of cross-fertilisation between Jewish and Quaker communities in the Netherlands and in England. So because Quakers are not respectable, they can't really make headway in their traditional professions. So they open shops. Right, so they're not Anglican, so therefore they can't go to Oxford and Cambridge, for instance. Exactly. And the other thing, of course, Herbarklers and Lloyds both have a Quaker history. They're the two banks. And as you said, Quakers become very sober. I mean, they are literally sober, aren't they? Because they're
就像犹太人和亚美尼亚人。在荷兰和英国，犹太社区和贵格会社区之间有很多交流。因为贵格会教徒不被主流社会尊重，他们在传统职业中很难取得进展。所以他们开了商店。对，他们不是圣公会教徒，所以他们不能去牛津和剑桥，例如。没错。当然，还有一点，巴克莱银行和劳埃德银行都有贵格会的历史。它们是两家银行。正如你所说，贵格会教徒变得非常清醒。我的意思是，他们字面上也是清醒的，不是吗？因为他们
all about temperance. Yeah, so they're not drinking wine. Exactly. So it's like the poor Italian in Mexico. There's no wine. Yes. And so he ends up having to drink chocolate. Had he been a Quaker, he'd probably have got stuck into the chocolate straight away but this is why quakers are getting into chocolate is it because it's an alternative to exactly so there are two families in particular two quaker families who are who are really interesting in the history of britain and chocolate and it is britain that is a chocolate pioneer in many ways in the 19th century and ends up leading the world in chocolate hooray yeah top nation tom it's so many respects and chocolate just happens to be one of them.
都主张节制。是的，所以他们不喝葡萄酒。没错。所以这就像墨西哥那个可怜的意大利人。没有酒。是的。所以他最后不得不喝巧克力。如果他是个贵格会教徒，他可能早就开始喝巧克力了，但这就是为什么贵格会教徒开始涉足巧克力，是因为它是替代品吗？没错，所以有两个家族，特别是两个贵格会家族，在英国和巧克力的历史上非常有趣，而且英国在19世纪确实在很多方面是巧克力的先驱，并最终在巧克力方面领先世界。万岁，是的，顶级国家，汤姆，在很多方面都是，而巧克力恰好是其中之一。
What can I say? So the first one is the fries. So there's a guy called Joseph Fry. He's a very austere, you know, plain clothes, keeps his hat on, that kind of Quaker. He starts an apothecary business
我能说什么呢？所以第一个是弗莱家族。有一个叫约瑟夫·弗莱的人。他非常朴素，你知道，穿着朴素，戴着帽子，就是那种贵格会教徒。他开了一家药剂店
in Bristol in 1753. Is he from Bristol? Yeah, you're going to do a Bristol accent. No, mate. Brilliant. People will love that. He sells chocolate from his ap do a Bristol accent. No, mate. Brilliant. People will love that. He sells chocolate from his apothecary shop. Obviously, it's medicinal, but he sells it, interestingly, to people in newly fashionable Bath.
1753年在布里斯托尔。他是布里斯托尔人吗？是的，你要模仿布里斯托尔口音吗？不，伙计。太棒了。人们会喜欢的。他从他的药剂店卖巧克力。显然，这是药用的，但有趣的是，他把它卖给了当时新潮的巴斯的人们。
Oh, does he? Yes. It's Babylon, isn't it? To a Quaker. Yeah. But he's turning up. Would you like a chocolate? Exactly.
哦，是吗？是的。那是巴比伦，不是吗？对一个贵格会教徒来说。是的。但他出现了。你想来点巧克力吗？没错。
Exactly. So when Jane Austen was in Bath, she might have drunk some chocolate. When Nelson was recuperating in Bath, he might have drunk chocolate. So Fry does very well at this. He sends agents out by the 1760s to 50 different towns in England. And what is it that's enabling him to sell it where other people haven't? He's making very good quality hot chocolate. He has some interesting press that he uses to grind the machines.
没错。所以当简·奥斯汀在巴斯时，她可能喝过一些巧克力。当纳尔逊在巴斯疗养时，他可能喝过巧克力。所以弗莱在这方面做得很好。到18世纪60年代，他派代理人去了英国50个不同的城镇。是什么让他能在别人没能卖出去的地方卖出去呢？他制作了质量非常好的热巧克力。他有一些有趣的压榨机，用来研磨机器。
Would you like my top quality chocolate? He has a cocoa manufacturing. Does he? And he uses water power to grind. So he's industrializing. He's an industrialist. It's the industrialization of chocolate. It is.
你想尝尝我的顶级巧克力吗？他有一个可可制造厂。真的吗？他用水力来研磨。所以他正在工业化。他是一位实业家。这是巧克力的工业化。确实是。
That's what's so interesting because what is more, he has a relative called Joseph Storrs Fry who takes control of the company in 1795. He grinds the beans, Tom, using a James Watt steam engine. Wow, it's all kicking off, isn't it? So it is the Industrial Revolution. I mean, basically, you have cocoa factories.
这才是最有趣的地方，因为更重要的是，他有一个亲戚叫约瑟夫·斯托尔斯·弗莱，他在1795年接管了公司。汤姆，他用詹姆斯·瓦特的蒸汽机研磨豆子。哇，一切都开始了，不是吗？所以这就是工业革命。我的意思是，基本上，你有了可可工厂。
And do you think that's why Britain becomes top chocolate nation? I totally think that. So by the early 1800s, the Frys have the biggest cocoa works in the world. That is such a source of patriotic pride it is but there's bad form to come because actually the dutch are still hanging around oh no everybody thinks that dutch history has ended in 1688 when they came to england but no actually still going on is it yes there's a father and son they're called the van houtens casparas and kudrad van houten and in the 18s, it turns out that they invent a machine.
你认为这就是英国成为顶级巧克力国家的原因吗？我完全这么认为。所以到19世纪初，弗莱家族拥有世界上最大的可可工厂。这真是爱国自豪感的源泉，确实如此，但还有坏消息要来，因为实际上荷兰人还在周围徘徊。哦，不，每个人都认为荷兰的历史在1688年他们来到英国时就结束了，但没有，实际上还在继续，是吗？是的，有一对父子，他们叫范豪滕，卡斯帕拉斯和库德拉德·范豪滕，在18世纪，事实证明他们发明了一台机器。
Now, this is complicated, Tom. We're not the rest is mechanics. I should look forward to it. You're explicating it for me, though. This machine, it presses the fat from roasted cocoa beans. How does it do that, Dominic? Well, you bring down one thing and then it presses out something else. The fat oozes out, doesn't it?
现在，这很复杂，汤姆。我们不是，剩下的就是机械了。我应该期待它。不过你是在为我解释。这台机器，它把脂肪从烤过的可可豆中压出来。多米尼克，它是怎么做到的？嗯，你把一个东西压下去，然后它就压出了别的东西。脂肪渗出来了，不是吗？
So the center of the bean, as you will know called the it's called the nib the nib the nib and uh the uh center of the bean has a lot of natural fat in it and basically it's a hydraulic press and it presses this out as sort of a cake of cocoa powder with fat sans fat there's no fat in it but now what you do you mix that powder with sugar and then you mix it with the now what you do, you mix that powder with sugar, and then you mix it with the fat, the cocoa butter that you pressed out. That creates a solid, and this is chocolate that you would eat. So the Dutch, it's always the way with the Dutch, isn't it? They're the great sort of...
所以豆子的中心，正如你所知，被称为“nib”（可可碎粒），nib，nib，而且豆子的中心有很多天然脂肪，基本上它是一个液压机，它把这些压出来，形成一种不含脂肪的可可粉饼，没有脂肪在里面，但现在你要做的是，把粉末和糖混合，然后你把它和现在你要做的是，把粉末和糖混合，然后你把它和脂肪，也就是你压出来的可可脂混合。这创造了一种固体，这就是你可以吃的巧克力。所以荷兰人，总是这样，不是吗？他们是伟大的那种……
They get there first, and then we nick it. And then they make a mess of it, and then they don't properly monetize it. I don't see that as a thing to be proud of. I mean, that's what happens to Britain as well. Look at our amazing lead in hovercrafts. Yes, hovercrafts and home computers. Yeah, we blew it all. Now, we said there were two Quaker families.
他们先到了那里，然后我们偷走了它。然后他们搞砸了，然后他们没有适当地将其货币化。我不认为这有什么值得骄傲的。我的意思是，英国也发生了同样的事情。看看我们在气垫船方面的惊人领先地位。是的，气垫船和家用电脑。是的，我们把一切都搞砸了。现在，我们说有两个贵格会家族。
Yes. Important now that we unveil the other one. Have we now arrived at Cadbury? Yeah, Cadbury. So they are from Birmingham. Oh, right. Which is nice. My dad.
是的。现在揭晓另一个很重要。我们到吉百利了吗？是的，吉百利。所以他们来自伯明翰。哦，对。这很好。我爸爸。
Yes. So the Holland family are from Birmingham, aren't they? Yeah. The workshop of the world, Tom. Second city of the empire in the 19th century. Yeah. The great boom town of kind of late 18th century, early 19th century. Britain, I suppose, to some extent, the successor to Manchester as the kind of crucible of modernity.
是的。所以霍兰家族来自伯明翰，不是吗？是的。世界的车间，汤姆。19世纪帝国的第二大城市。是的。18世纪末、19世纪初的伟大繁荣城镇。英国，我想，在某种程度上，是曼彻斯特的继任者，作为现代性的熔炉。
Yeah. So absolutely the kind of place that would love a chocolate bar. Kind of the most cutting edge place in the world. Food that you can get. Yes. Most. Kind of the most cutting edge... Place in the world....food that you can get. Yes, most cutting edge place, most cutting edge food. So in 1824, this chap called John Cadbury, who's a Quaker, he opens a shop at 93 Bull Street, Birmingham, and he sells tea, coffee, and cocoa.
是的。所以绝对是那种会喜欢巧克力棒的地方。世界上最前沿的地方。你能得到的食物。是的。最。那种最前沿……世界上最前沿的地方……你能得到的食物。是的，最前沿的地方，最前沿的食物。所以1824年，这个叫约翰·吉百利的人，他是个贵格会教徒，他在伯明翰公牛街93号开了一家店，卖茶、咖啡和可可。
So at that point, in his mind, it's a drink, and it's kind of, you know, it coexists with tea and coffee. He grinds his own beans in a pestle and mortar, very time-consuming, no doubt. But he opens a factory in 1831 and he, like Fry, is inspired by
所以在当时，在他看来，这是一种饮料，而且它，你知道，与茶和咖啡共存。他用研钵和研杵研磨自己的豆子，毫无疑问非常耗时。但他1831年开了一家工厂，他像弗莱一样，受到
this Dutch machine. Right. The difference between Cadbury and their competitors is that they are much more high-end. Well, of course. I mean,
这台荷兰机器的启发。对。吉百利和他们的竞争对手之间的区别在于他们更高端。嗯，当然。我的意思是，
it's the best kind of chocolate, isn't it? So, listen, their competitors will, I'm sorry to say, this reflects poorly on Britain, they will adulterate their chocolate powder
这是最好的巧克力，不是吗？所以，听着，他们的竞争对手会，我很遗憾地说，这反映了英国的糟糕，他们会掺假他们的巧克力粉
with brick dust with brick dust or with lead that's very kind of Charles Dickens isn't it it is kind of hard times
用砖粉，用砖粉或铅，这很像查尔斯·狄更斯，不是吗？这确实有点像《艰难时世》。
but Cadbury's don't do that they do have potato flour in there and a bit of treacle and a bit of sago but who doesn't have a bit of that
但吉百利不那样做，他们确实在里面放了马铃薯粉、一点糖蜜和一点西米，但谁没有一点这些呢？
a lot of people would pay good money for that and in fact they do but not brick dust and not vipers or earthworms or the gall of eels.
很多人会为此花大钱，事实上他们也确实这么做了，但不是砖粉，也不是毒蛇或蚯蚓或鳗鱼胆。
And actually, John Cadbury gets a reputation. People say he is the chocolatier to the stars. He is the chocolatier to Queen Victoria, no less, because he gets a royal warrant. So she is amused. Any other cocoa manufacturer, he makes a line called Queen's Own Chocolate. The purple coloring that so many people associate with Cadbury. Purple wrapping paper. Was the royal purple, Tom.
事实上，约翰·吉百利赢得了声誉。人们说他是明星的巧克力商。他确实是维多利亚女王的巧克力商，因为他获得了皇家授权。所以她很开心。任何其他可可制造商，他制作了一个名为“女王自有巧克力”的系列。许多人与吉百利联系在一起的紫色。紫色包装纸。是皇家紫，汤姆。
Oh, yeah. They would have wrappers with the likeness of Victorian Albert on them, which is lovely. So Cadbury was doing really well by the 1860s or so. It was very high-end, posh chocolate. His sons, Richard and George, take it over. But they still have the issue that all the chocolate companies have, is how do you differentiate yourselves from your rivals? Fruit and nut.
哦，是的。他们会有印有维多利亚和阿尔伯特肖像的包装纸，这很可爱。所以到1860年代左右，吉百利做得非常好。那是很高档、时髦的巧克力。他的儿子理查德和乔治接管了它。但他们仍然面临所有巧克力公司都有的问题，那就是你如何将自己与竞争对手区分开来？水果和坚果。
Well, not at this point, Tom. I know you like a fruit and nut. I rivals fruit and nut well not at this point Tom I know you like a fruit and nut I love fruit and nut but no actually what they think of as their secret weapon is a thing called
嗯，在这一点上不是，汤姆。我知道你喜欢水果和坚果。我竞争对手水果和坚果，嗯，在这一点上不是，汤姆。我知道你喜欢水果和坚果，我喜欢水果和坚果，但实际上他们认为的秘密武器是一种叫做
Iceland moss Iceland moss yes is it literally moss it's lichen oh yeah they blend the two
冰岛苔藓的东西。冰岛苔藓，是的，它真的是苔藓吗？它是地衣。哦，是的，他们把两者混合在一起。
bizarrely it's sold in yellow packaging you don't often see a yellow package and what's the point of this they say it's got a reindeer
奇怪的是，它以黄色包装出售，你很少看到黄色包装，这有什么意义呢？他们说它有一只驯鹿
on the packaging and it shows how healthy it is right it's very healthy because you're getting some moss some lichen
在包装上，它显示了它有多健康，对吧？它非常健康，因为你得到了一些苔藓，一些地衣，
and you're getting some chocolate and it's from Iceland but it seems a weird thing I mean because people aren't normally tucking I mean you would have
你得到了一些巧克力，而且它来自冰岛，但这似乎是一件奇怪的事情，我的意思是，因为人们通常不会吃，我的意思是你会
fruit and you would have nut and so the presence of fruit and nut in a Cadbury chocolate bar you've got fruit and nut on the brain Tom I'm rather hoping
有水果，你会有坚果，所以吉百利巧克力棒中水果和坚果的存在，你脑子里全是水果和坚果，汤姆，我倒是希望
to become an influencer right get fruit and nut chocolate bars I'm holding. I'm rather hoping to become an influencer. Right. Get fruit and nut chocolate bars. I'm holding out for an Iceland moss contract. But lichen. Yeah. Nobody eats that. Do you want to know what the aptly named historian Deborah Cadbury says about Iceland moss, Tom?
成为一名网红，对吧？得到我手里拿的水果和坚果巧克力棒。我倒是希望成为一名网红。对。得到水果和坚果巧克力棒。我在等一份冰岛苔藓的合同。但是地衣。是的。没人吃那个。你想知道恰如其分的历史学家黛博拉·吉百利是怎么评价冰岛苔藓的吗，汤姆？
Yeah, tell me. The untried combination of fluffy textured lichen and fatty cocoa bean would not excite the English palate. Right. Now, they mention the wrapper, the yellow wrapper with its reindeer. This is quite a new departure for a Quaker company because the Quakers had hitherto been very suspicious of puffery. So that's advertising? Advertising.
是的，告诉我。蓬松质地的地衣和油腻的可可豆的未经尝试的组合不会刺激英国人的味蕾。对。现在，他们提到了包装纸，带有驯鹿的黄色包装纸。这对一家贵格会公司来说是一个相当新的出发点，因为贵格会教徒迄今为止一直非常怀疑这种吹嘘。所以那是广告？广告。
Well, they would be, yeah. But by the late 1860s, actually Cadbury are leading the world in advertising. Are they? They are. They get endorsements from The Lancet and the British Medical Journal. What's that?
嗯，他们会是的，是的。但到1860年代末，实际上吉百利在广告方面处于世界领先地位。是吗？他们是。他们得到了《柳叶刀》和《英国医学杂志》的背书。那是什么？
Chocolate is good for you? Chocolate is good for you. Medicinal. Mix it with an earthworm. Brilliant. You're laughing. They have picture boxes, which previously Quakers had been very suspicious of. Don't put pictures on your chocolate.
巧克力对你有好处？巧克力对你有好处。药用。把它和蚯蚓混合。太棒了。你在笑。他们有图片盒，以前贵格会教徒对此非常怀疑。不要在你的巧克力上放图片。
And what pictures? What are they? Of Queen Victoria. Right. Or here's one. A Birmingham Gazette says, pictorial novelties. Chaste yet simple. A blue-eyed maiden maiden some six summers old
什么图片？它们是什么？维多利亚女王的。对。或者这里有一个。《伯明翰公报》说，图画新奇事物。纯洁而简单。一个蓝眼睛的少女，大约六个夏天大，
designed and drawn by Mr. Richard Cadbury okay so a little bit of Victorian yeah sentimentalism exactly they launched their first
由理查德·吉百利先生设计和绘制，好吧，所以有一点维多利亚时代的，是的，感伤主义，没错，他们推出了他们的第一个
Easter egg in 1875 and they also go very upmarket so they're very very upmarket their slogan is absolutely pure therefore best in the world
复活节彩蛋在1875年，他们也走非常高端的路线，所以他们非常非常高端，他们的口号是“绝对纯净，因此是世界上最好的”，
which reminds me Dominic so while this is happening in Britain yes the Americans must surely be developing, I mean, no offence to our American listeners, chocolate, but they're terrible chocolate. Terrible chocolate.
这让我想起了多米尼克，所以当这种情况在英国发生时，是的，美国人肯定在发展，我的意思是，无意冒犯我们的美国听众，巧克力，但他们是糟糕的巧克力。糟糕的巧克力。
And the Swiss? The Swiss are latecomers, Lindt and Nestle. They invented a thing called the conching machine. I don't really understand how that works, quite frankly. But what's the effect? It conches the chocolate and it makes it very smooth. But yeah, you're absolutely right to raise the issue of American chocolate. That is a huge puzzle because they've obviously got an enormous market,
那瑞士人呢？瑞士人是后来者，瑞士莲和雀巢。他们发明了一种叫做精炼机的机器。坦率地说，我不太明白它是如何工作的。但效果是什么？它精炼巧克力，使它非常光滑。但是的，你提出美国巧克力的问题绝对是对的。这是一个巨大的谜题，因为他们显然有一个巨大的市场，
but their chocolate is, I mean, it's abhorrent and abject, isn't it, Tom, without being rude to our members? Like their cheese. Like their cheese. Yeah, what's going on? Anyway, maybe our American listeners, if they're already left, will let us know in no uncertain terms. So anyway, that's the product.
但他们的巧克力是，我的意思是，它是令人厌恶和卑劣的，不是吗，汤姆，在不对我们的成员无礼的情况下？像他们的奶酪。像他们的奶酪。是的，发生了什么事？无论如何，也许我们的美国听众，如果他们已经离开了，会明确地告诉我们。所以无论如何，这就是产品。
That's what Cadbury are selling. But actually, the really interesting thing is where they are making it and what their workers are doing. Are they making it outside Birmingham? They are, Tom. They are. So they're still making it in Birmingham.
这就是吉百利在卖的东西。但实际上，真正有趣的是他们在哪里制造它以及他们的工人在做什么。他们在伯明翰之外制造它吗？是的，汤姆。他们是。所以他们仍然在伯明翰制造它。
In 1878, they bought some rural farmland just outside the city through which a stream runs called the Bourne. Right. And they call this Bourneville. So French for town. Exactly. Calling things ville at this point is seen as quite an upmarket Frenchified thing to do.
1878年，他们通过一条流经的溪流“伯恩”，在城市外买了一些农村农田。对。他们称之为“伯恩维尔”。所以是法语的城镇。没错。在这一点上称事物为“ville”被认为是一件相当高端的法语化事情。
Now, the Bourneville factory becomes the sort of physical embodiment of the Quaker principles that the family actually still espouse. So George Cadbury, who's now the big cheese in the family, he'd been a teacher in a school for working men in Birmingham. He was really into kind of liberal-minded campaigns in the sort of 1860s, 1870s. So against chimney sweeps. Against chimney sweeps, exactly, exactly. Lord Shaftesbury. Give people better conditions, better housing, clean things up.
现在，伯恩维尔工厂成为了该家族实际上仍然信奉的贵格会原则的某种物理体现。所以乔治·吉百利，现在是家族中的大人物，他曾是伯明翰一所工人学校的老师。他非常热衷于1860年代、1870年代那种自由思想的运动。所以反对烟囱清扫工。反对烟囱清扫工，没错，没错。沙夫茨伯里勋爵。给人们更好的条件，更好的住房，清理干净。
I mean, it's part of that sort of Joseph Chamberlain era. Well, it's the kind of the high-minded Victorian spirit that people laugh at. Yeah. But we have not earned the right to laugh at because it's completely admirable. I couldn't agree with you more. So as an employer, I mean, he is obviously very paternalistic. But as you say, he's very admirable. He says, let's have bank holidays. Let's have a five and a half day working week.
我的意思是，这是那种约瑟夫·张伯伦时代的一部分。嗯，这是人们嘲笑的那种高尚的维多利亚精神。是的。但我们没有权利嘲笑，因为它完全令人钦佩。我完全同意你的看法。所以作为雇主，我的意思是，他显然非常家长式。但正如你所说，他非常令人钦佩。他说，让我们有银行假日。让我们有每周五天半的工作制。
I mean, this is a time when a lot of employers don't give people so much as a minute's break all week. He gives the workers more rights, better conditions, all that kind of thing. And then by the 1890s, he starts to go well beyond that and to become a real pioneer so what he does in the 1890s he buys 120 acres of land by the factory uh and he says i'm going to plan a model village bourneville and it will and i quote alleviate the evils of modern more cramped living conditions so that's 1893 they start rebuilding it in 1894 and by 1900 they do build things a lot more quickly than uh than we do in 1900 they have basically built this village out of nowhere it has more than 300 cottages and houses have you been to bourneville uh no i've never been have you not but i have read jonathan co's brilliant
我的意思是，这是一个许多雇主整周都不给人们哪怕一分钟休息时间的时代。他给了工人更多的权利，更好的条件，所有这些事情。然后到1890年代，他开始超越这一点，成为真正的先驱，所以他在1890年代所做的是，他在工厂旁边买了120英亩土地，他说我要规划一个模范村庄“伯恩维尔”，它将，我引用，“减轻现代更拥挤的生活条件的弊端”，所以那是1893年，他们在1894年开始重建它，到1900年，他们建造东西的速度比我们快得多，在1900年，他们基本上从无到有建造了这个村庄，它有超过300个小屋和房子，你去过伯恩维尔吗？嗯，没有，我从来没去过，你没有吗？但我读过乔纳森·科的精彩
novel bourneville yeah which is all about it right it's it's a really i mean if you were going to live in a suburb that's where you'd live but isn't this near where tolkien moves yeah he gets very upset about it and basically compares it to mordor but the weird thing is that tolkien should like it because like all of these sort of garden villages the 1890s it's quite shire like yeah the buildings are kind of you know late victorian edwardian vernacular english vernacular they're kind of hamster garden suburb yeah hamster exactly that they are kind of very bit william morrissey they're meant to be a little bit arts and craftsy so they're modern inside by the standards of the time but they are very much done in a kind of traditional english style you know it's it's a sort of it's
小说《伯恩维尔》，是的，全是关于它的，对吧？它真的，我的意思是，如果你要住在郊区，那就是你会住的地方，但这不就在托尔金搬去的地方附近吗？是的，他对此非常不安，基本上把它比作魔多，但奇怪的是，托尔金应该喜欢它，因为像所有这些1890年代的花园村庄一样，它很像夏尔，是的，建筑是那种，你知道，维多利亚晚期、爱德华时代的本土风格，英国本土风格，它们有点像汉普斯特德花园郊区，是的，汉普斯特德，没错，它们非常威廉·莫里斯风格，它们旨在有一点工艺美术风格，所以它们在当时的标准下内部是现代的，但它们确实是以一种传统的英国风格完成的，你知道，这是一种
it's the country in the city as it were russin urbe. Exactly so. And it has a very, you know, 1900s kind of team spirit ethos, the age of the Boy Scouts and so on. So they have evening classes. And actually if you want to get a job at Bourneville in 1910 or something and you are a young person, one of the conditions of your employment is that you will have to go to evening classes and be improved. And how do we feel about that? I think it's brilliant.
城市中的乡村，正如人们所说，“rus in urbe”。确实如此。而且它有一种非常1900年代的那种团队精神精神，童子军时代等等。所以他们有夜校。实际上，如果你想在1910年左右在伯恩维尔找工作，而你是一个年轻人，你就业的条件之一就是你必须去上夜校并得到提升。我们对此感觉如何？我认为这太棒了。
That's what football clubs do, Tom, with their apprentices. They force them to study. I don't think they make them do Latin, but they make them do maths or something. Right. Quite right too. There are lots of games. There are games for women, interestingly, sports for women. And then they do them in work time.
汤姆，这就是足球俱乐部对他们的学徒所做的。他们强迫他们学习。我不认为他们让他们学拉丁语，但他们让他们学数学之类的。对。确实如此。有很多游戏。有趣的是，有女性的游戏，女性的运动。而且他们在工作时间做这些。
So they have two half-hour sessions a week. They don't lose pay. They're paid to go to those sessions a week they don't lose pay they're paid to go to those sessions and they sort of play ball games and do gymnastics and stuff and the thinking is they'll be healthy but also they'll be better workers and obviously there's no opportunity to go and get drunk no exactly but you can go for a restorative chocolate yes you after the after your ball game so it's just like uh central america and yeah So it's just like Central America. Yeah, exactly. It's like the Olmecs.
所以他们每周有两个半小时的课程。他们不会损失工资。他们被付钱去参加那些每周的课程，他们不会损失工资，他们被付钱去参加那些课程，他们玩球类游戏和做体操之类的，想法是他们会健康，但他们也会成为更好的工人，显然没有机会去喝醉，不，没错，但你可以去喝一杯恢复性的巧克力，是的，在你玩完球类游戏之后，所以这就像中美洲，是的，所以这就像中美洲。是的，没错。就像奥尔梅克人。
AD-1000. Exactly. Ball games and chocolate. There is a company culture. They're one of the first companies, if not the first company, to have a genuine company culture. So they have the Bourneville Works magazine that's launched in 1902.
公元1000年。没错。球类游戏和巧克力。有一种公司文化。他们是第一批拥有真正公司文化的公司之一，如果不是第一家的话。所以他们有1902年创刊的《伯恩维尔工厂杂志》。
There is this sort of spirit that actually is easy. People sneer at it now, or they sniff at it and say it's very paternalistic. But the ethos of the magazine, I'll read you the quote. To promote what, for lack of a better word, we may describe as the Bourneville spirit. To foster comradeship and good fellowship.
确实有这种精神，实际上很容易。人们现在嘲笑它，或者他们嗤之以鼻，说它非常家长式。但杂志的精神，我给你读一下引文。促进我们可能称之为“伯恩维尔精神”的东西，因为没有更好的词。培养同志情谊和良好的友谊。
And to add one more to the links binding together the community at Bourneville in mutual service. That is quite Tolkien, isn't it? It is a bit Tolkien, I think. It is quite Fellowship of the Ring. Yeah. And they deliver on a lot of these promises. So they have a benefit scheme. They have a pension scheme. So pensions, as our community manager, James Regan, would be the first person to say, were brought in famously by his hero, H. H. Asquith.
并为将伯恩维尔社区在相互服务中联系在一起的纽带再增加一条。那很托尔金，不是吗？我认为这有点托尔金。这很像《指环王》。是的。他们兑现了许多这些承诺。所以他们有福利计划。他们有养老金计划。所以养老金，正如我们的社区经理詹姆斯·里根会第一个说的那样，是由他的英雄H.H.阿斯奎斯著名地引入的。
Actually, Bourneville got there first. So men had pensions in 1996. So even better than Asquith. I mean, that is high praise. That is the highest praise. Actually, Asquith is not a man who would have drunk chocolate, is he? No. A temperance town would not have been to his taste. No. And Bourneville still has. There's more than 20,000 people there.
实际上，伯恩维尔先做到了。所以男人们在1996年就有养老金了。所以甚至比阿斯奎斯更好。我的意思是，那是高度赞扬。那是最高的赞扬。实际上，阿斯奎斯不是一个会喝巧克力的人，是吗？不。一个节制城镇不会合他的口味。不。而且伯恩维尔仍然有。那里有超过20,000人。
Are you aware of the work of the actress Felicity Jones? I don't know. Was she Stephen Hawking's wife in that film with Eddie Redmayne? Didn't see it. She was also, we did an episode about Star Wars, she was the lead in Rogue One, which is an excellent film. Argu arguably the best of the recent star wars films she's from bourneville is she so there's a lovely fact wonderful so that's bourneville shall we get back to uh chocolate tom before we completely run out of time yes so the great news for people who uh like british chocolate is that uh as we approach the first world war britain leads the world unquestionably
你知道女演员费莉西蒂·琼斯的作品吗？我不知道。她是那部和埃迪·雷德梅恩一起演的电影里斯蒂芬·霍金的妻子吗？没看。她也是，我们做了一集关于《星球大战》的节目，她是《侠盗一号》的主角，那是一部出色的电影。可以说是最近的《星球大战》电影中最好的一部，她来自伯恩维尔，是吗？所以这是一个可爱的、美妙的事实，所以那是伯恩维尔，我们在完全没时间之前回到巧克力，汤姆，好吗？是的，所以对于喜欢英国巧克力的人来说，好消息是，随着我们接近第一次世界大战，英国毫无疑问地领先世界。
great days in the chocolate so cadbury is now the world, unquestionably, in the chocolate. So Cadbury is now the world's biggest chocolate producer and is by far the biggest exporter because, of course, it has the empire. So we're exporting Cadbury chocolate, fries, round trees, all this stuff. Very, very exciting moment. In 1905, the most famous chocolate bar in the world is launched, Tom. That chocolate bar is, of course, the Dairy Milk. The interesting thing about the Dairy Milk is that the emphasis is very much on the milk and not on the chocolate.
巧克力的大日子，所以吉百利现在是世界，毫无疑问，在巧克力方面。所以吉百利现在是世界上最大的巧克力生产商，并且是迄今为止最大的出口商，因为当然，它拥有帝国。所以我们在出口吉百利巧克力、弗莱、朗特里，所有这些东西。非常非常令人兴奋的时刻。1905年，世界上最著名的巧克力棒推出了，汤姆。那块巧克力棒当然就是“Dairy Milk”。关于“Dairy Milk”有趣的是，重点非常多地放在牛奶上，而不是巧克力上。
So this is more Quaker. Yeah. You know, healthy glass of milk. The logo is still a glass of milk, I think, isn't it? Yeah, it is. And actually, the names they considered before they went for Dairy Milk were calling it either a Highland Milk Bar or a Dairy Maid Bar. Dairy Maid. And they went for Dairy Milk. Dairy Maid,. Dairy Maid. And they went for dairy milk.
所以这更贵格会。是的。你知道，健康的牛奶杯。标志仍然是一杯牛奶，我想，不是吗？是的，它是。实际上，在他们选择“Dairy Milk”之前考虑的名字是称它为“Highland Milk Bar”或“Dairy Maid Bar”。Dairy Maid。他们选择了“Dairy Milk”。Dairy Maid，Dairy Maid。他们选择了“Dairy Milk”。
Dairy Maid, I think, is an ice cream, an ice lolly. Is it? They had dairy made ice lollies. There's milk made ice lollies, aren't there? Yeah, maybe. I didn't like them. However, Tom, I'm sorry to say the Great War, you know my views on the Great War. Anyway, that's by the by.
Dairy Maid，我想是一种冰淇淋，一种冰棒。是吗？他们有Dairy Maid冰棒。有牛奶冰棒，不是吗？是的，也许。我不喜欢它们。然而，汤姆，我很遗憾地说，大战，你知道我对大战的看法。无论如何，那是题外话。
It all went wrong and it was bad news for chocolate and for chocolate firms. Oh, specifically for British chocolate. Yeah. There's one bit of good news. Surely it's good news for American chocolate, isn't it? It is. Yeah. So British chocolate makers, they supplied the soldiers in their trenches with chocolate.
一切都出错了，这对巧克力和巧克力公司来说是个坏消息。哦，特别是对英国巧克力。是的。有一个好消息。这肯定对美国巧克力是个好消息，不是吗？它是。是的。所以英国巧克力制造商，他们为战壕里的士兵提供了巧克力。
So you've got chocolate as part of your ration. And this was, I mean, Cadbury's did that. Cadbury. Cadbury did it. And they provided books and clothing for the troops as well. International competitors like Nestle and Lindt were completely frozen out of that for obvious reasons. What about Hershey's?
所以你把巧克力作为你配给的一部分。这，我的意思是，吉百利做了。吉百利。吉百利做了。他们也为军队提供了书籍和衣服。像雀巢和瑞士莲这样的国际竞争对手因为显而易见的原因完全被排除在外。那好时呢？
Hershey's. I mean, who would have Hershey's? Would you have Hershey's chocolate? I guess the GIs? They would, but they didn't turn up until 1918 or something, did they? So, I mean, that's by the by. It does lead to greater cooperation between the different Quaker companies. They've been talking about this actually since before the First World War. We're all Quakers. Kind of joining up. Let's join up and have one massive Quaker chocolate company.
好时。我的意思是，谁会吃好时？你会吃好时巧克力吗？我猜是美国大兵？他们会，但他们直到1918年左右才出现，不是吗？所以，我的意思是，那是题外话。这确实导致了不同贵格会公司之间更紧密的合作。实际上，他们在第一次世界大战之前就在谈论这个了。我们都是贵格会教徒。某种联合。让我们联合起来，拥有一家巨大的贵格会巧克力公司。
They have massive shortages of milk and sugar. And so some of them are struggling. So fries, for example. By 1918, they're talking about, why don't we absolutely do this and merge into one big company? The Roundtree company says no. But the fries company say, yeah, let's do it. So in 1919, they form a company with the splendid name of the British Cocoa and Chocolate Company. It's not as catchy as Cadbury.
他们有大量的牛奶和糖短缺。所以他们中的一些人在挣扎。例如弗莱。到1918年，他们正在谈论，为什么我们不绝对这样做并合并成一家大公司？朗特里公司说不。但弗莱公司说，是的，让我们做吧。所以1919年，他们组建了一家公司，名字叫“英国可可和巧克力公司”。它不像吉百利那样朗朗上口。
Well, okay. I mean, if that's your view, Tom, I'm clearly not going to persuade you. So Britain comes out of the war. And actually, I think in some ways you could say, this is the point at which chocolate is completely embedded tom in british national life to a degree that's exceptional i think it is exceptional actually i think there are more products in britain there are more consumers um there's a greater volume of production than anywhere else in the world and have they started adding bits of orange peel and yes fruit and nuts and you know you've all the bubbles into it yeah you're mad about the fruit and nuts and they absolutely are so you get uh the fruit and nut, the Bourneville fruit.
嗯，好吧。我的意思是，如果那是你的观点，汤姆，我显然不会说服你。所以英国从战争中走出来。实际上，我认为在某些方面你可以说，这是巧克力完全嵌入英国国民生活的一点，汤姆，程度是例外的，我认为它是例外的，实际上我认为英国有更多的产品，有更多的消费者，嗯，生产量比世界上任何其他地方都大，他们开始添加橘子皮碎片了吗？是的，水果和坚果，你知道，你所有的气泡都在里面，是的，你对水果和坚果很疯狂，他们绝对是，所以你得到了水果和坚果，伯恩维尔水果。
They make a dark fruit and nut before a milk one, interestingly. Oh, God, I love both. So the Bourneville fruit and nut is 1924. The milk fruit and nut is 1926. And the flake, when did you think flake was invented? 1932. 1920. And actually, there's some technical development that allows them to produce the flake,
有趣的是，他们在牛奶巧克力之前制作了一种黑巧克力水果和坚果。哦，天哪，我两者都喜欢。所以伯恩维尔水果和坚果是1924年的。牛奶水果和坚果是1926年的。还有Flake，你认为Flake是什么时候发明的？1932年。1920年。实际上，有一些技术发展使他们能够生产Flake，
but I don't understand what it is was it that thing that the it's not the conching no it wasn't conching no some other form of
但我不知道那是什么，是那个东西，它不是精炼，不，不是精炼，不，某种其他形式的
flake machine was it Dutch I think the Dutch are this they're out of history by this point they've been not out of history so there's more products
Flake机器，是荷兰的吗？我想荷兰人在这一点上已经退出了历史，他们没有退出历史，所以有更多的产品
and far far more people are eating chocolate so to give you an indication all that we've talked about actually was still a relatively elite thing and a middle class thing. So in 1900, only one in 30 families, households in Britain, ate chocolate regularly because it's expensive. And after the war, that's? By 1930, nine out of 10 families or households. And is that because lots of soldiers have got the habit of the trenches?
而且有更多更多的人在吃巧克力，所以给你一个指示，我们谈论的所有这些实际上仍然是一个相对精英的东西和一个中产阶级的东西。所以1900年，英国只有三十分之一的家庭经常吃巧克力，因为它很贵。而在战争之后，那是？到1930年，十分之九的家庭。这是因为很多士兵养成了战壕里的习惯吗？
But also it's really cheap. It's just technological advance, you know, innovations mean it can be produced much more cheaply. The price of a dairy milk fell by 70% in the decade after the Great War. So sales go through the roof. And now really the companies can say we are genuinely mass national enterprises. So the Bourneville Works magazine that I quoted before in 1934, they say very proudly, at Bourneville, we cater for the man in the street, his wife and family, the poor man at the gate rather than the
但它也很便宜。这只是技术进步，你知道，创新意味着它可以更便宜地生产。Dairy Milk的价格在第一次世界大战后的十年里下降了70%。所以销量飙升。现在公司真的可以说我们是真正的大众国民企业。所以我在1934年引用的《伯恩维尔工厂杂志》，他们非常自豪地说，在伯恩维尔，我们迎合街头的人，他的妻子和家人，门口的穷人，而不是
rich man in his castle. So it is a kind of long process of both globalization and democratization. It is. A product once given to King Philip II is now being given to the ordinary folk of Birmingham,
城堡里的富人。所以这是一个全球化和民主化的漫长过程。确实是。曾经给菲利普二世国王的产品现在正被给予伯明翰的普通民众，
their black country. It's a lovely story, Tom. And they say that history has no sense of progress. No. What nonsense. Well, you know what George Orwell said about chocolate
他们的黑国。这是一个可爱的故事，汤姆。他们说历史没有进步感。不。什么胡说八道。好吧，你知道乔治·奥威尔关于巧克力说了什么吗
and the Great Depression? So people carried on eating chocolate in the Depression. Did it involve clogs? Effectively. Orwell said, and I think it's in The Roads where We Can Peer, he said,
和大萧条？所以人们在大萧条时期继续吃巧克力。它涉及木屐吗？实际上。奥威尔说，我想是在《通往威根码头之路》里，他说，
It is quite likely that fish and chips, art silk stockings, tinned salmon, cut-priced chocolate, five two-ounce bars for sixpence. The movies, the radio, strong tea, and the football pools are between them averted revolution. Marvelous. Isn't it? It's lovely, Tom.
很有可能炸鱼薯条、人造丝长筒袜、罐装鲑鱼、降价巧克力、六便士买五条两盎司的巧克力棒。电影、广播、浓茶和足球彩票，它们共同避免了革命。太棒了。不是吗？这很可爱，汤姆。
Jumpers for goalposts. So it was chocolates that we have to thank for there being no British Revolution in the 1930s. And isn't that a lovely thought? And on that bombshell, many thanks to Cadbury for sponsoring us and Dominic giving us the opportunity to do this episode on chocolate
球门柱的套头衫。所以我们必须感谢巧克力，因为1930年代没有发生英国革命。这不是一个可爱的想法吗？带着这个重磅炸弹，非常感谢吉百利赞助我们，多米尼克给了我们机会做这一集关于巧克力的节目，
that we've been wanting to do for ages. We've been craving it, Tom. Yeah. I have to say that doing this episode has definitely sharpened my desire to have some fruit and nut. What's your favourite? I'll go on the record now. If anyone from Cadbury is listening, just, I mean, you don't have to send them, but I do like a double decker.
我们已经想做很久了。我们一直渴望它，汤姆。是的。我必须说，做这一集绝对增强了我吃一些水果和坚果的欲望。你最喜欢什么？我现在记录在案。如果吉百利有人在听，只是，我的意思是，你不必寄给他们，但我确实喜欢Double Decker。
Double decker. I'm a big fan of a double decker. With the nougat. I like the contrasting textures inside the double decker, Tom. So this is something that American chocolate does not get. Brilliant. Thank you very much for this wonderful tour through the history of chocolate. And thank you, everyone else, for listening.
Double Decker。我是Double Decker的忠实粉丝。有牛轧糖。我喜欢Double Decker里面对比鲜明的质地，汤姆。所以这是美国巧克力没有得到的东西。太棒了。非常感谢你这次美妙的巧克力历史之旅。也谢谢大家收听。
Bye-bye. Bye-bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。